Two more elements I'd like to teach you--these are called "span" and "div".
and are both normal elements.
They can both have content and the only difference between these two
is is inline
and is block.
We'll play around with these in the Editor a little bit,
but these are basically--
these elements don't do anything other than just contain their content.
And there's a way to attach styles to them,
to adjust different behaviors of how they display.
That looks something like this.
So you can see, I've added two attributes--
or an attribute to each of these, called "class".
And this is a CSS class,
and this is not something we're going to spend a whole lot of time on in this course.
I'll provide most of the CSS,
but it's a separate language for adding styles to your documents
or changing how different text looks.
And we'll be using and a lot
for controlling how text is laid out.
But the important thing to remember is that are inline
and are block.
Let's play around with these in a browser a little bit--real quick--
so you can see what I'm talking about.
Okay. So we've got our text
and our first line is wrapped in --
and it behaves as we would expect an inline element to behave.
Now if I were to change this to a ,
it behaves more like how the paragraph tag before behaved.
This actually creates a box around this piece of text.
And you can see--we actually did something interesting.
I added a little period after the
and the period up here is down on the second line here.
What I'd like you to do is check all of the elements that are inline.
Some of these elements you haven't seen before,
so I would like you to try them out in your own browser
and figure it out for yourself.